تخبرك صفارات الانذار هذه عن سلسله
انفجارات تطال العاصمه تكييف عقب ضربات
صاروخيه جديده استهدفت بمن تحتيه الرئيسيه
وفق مسؤولين اوكرانيا هذا هو الوضع هنا
اما في شرق اوكرانيا فتقف مدينه سوليدار
الصغيره بين تاكيد روسيا السيطره عليها
ونفي اوكرانيا تلك المعلومات
وفيسبريسكا التي تقع على بعد 25 كيلو مترا
شمال سوليدار دوت اصوات المدفعيه لتزيدما
خوف السكان من ان تكون الهدف التالي اما
في منطقه الشركسي فتعيشه هي الاخرى على
واقع تحذير حاكم المنطقه من احتمال وقوعه
هجوم صاروخين روسي كبير
الهجمات الروسيه طالت نيكولايف حيث تم
استهدافها بسبعه عشره قاذفه روسيه حسبما
افاد حاكم من تقع فيما تعرضت منطقه تركيب
في شمال الشرقيه ايضا له صاروخيه الضربات
الروسيه استهدفت كذلك منشات حيويه في
الفيف وفق مسؤولين اوكران كما سجلت هجمات
في الجنوب الاوكرانيه في المنطقه ذا
بوريجيا
نيران الحرب في اوكرانيا تشتد اشتعالا
يوما بعد يوما هجوم تلو الاخر فيما تحاول
روسيا ومن خلال تسانتها الحربيه فرض
سيطرتها على مناطق جديده وتضييق الخناق
على العاصمه